praise neuro mods gives Morgan a whole
host of abilities and upgrades to help
them survive Talos one there's
technically no wrong path to pick with
the game encouraging a variety of play
styles from guns to stealth to turning
into a cup for stealth and then using
your gun but we do feel there are some
key abilities you should unlock no
matter what to help you take advantage
of everything the game has to offer
so give us a sub if you end up finding
this video useful now start fabricating
those neuro mods and get ready to
upgrade prey is perhaps the first game
to ever get me to care about recycling
as it is a huge component of the game
and key to making sure you are stocked
up on plenty of ammo and med kits but
before you start recycling too much
you'll want to pick up materials expert
which increases recycling yield by 20%
get this one right away and before you
know it you'll be swimming in materials
now one of the rarer materials in the
game is the exotic material which comes
from the Typhoon's
and you may have noticed that there's
always an extra organ from Thai things
you can't take with you that's because
you need the necropsy upgrade get this
as soon as you can so you can start
harvesting and then recycling for more
exotic material what can you do with the
exotic material fabricate more neural
mods of course
you may notice holding all of these
alien organs along with several shotguns
and a whole bars worth of alcohol fills
up that inventory space pretty quickly
investing in all three levels of suit
modifications increases your inventory
space and also adds more chipset slots
meaning you have to spend less time
running back to the recycler now let's
talk exploration if you're like me and
you want to explore every room possible
and more importantly read everyone's
private emails there are a number of
abilities you need to get first is
leverage which lets you move heavy
objects a lot of doors throughout Talos
1 are barricaded off and getting
yourself to level 3 leverage as quickly
as possible lets you get access to these
places quicker
now once you've busted into someone's
office you'll want to get into their
stuff you could spend your time looking
for a password for their computer or a
key code for the safe but you can always
hack your way through instead hacking
may not seem that important at the
beginning when pass codes are on sticky
notes attached to the screen but it's
great in the latter half of the game
when pass codes become harder to find
and some don't even give you the option
meaning your only choice is to hack
hacking is also pretty important if you
start installing alien powers into
yourself the more alien power you have
the more alien your DNA becomes and
eventually the station's turrets will
see you as a threat and shoot you on
sight
however a quick hack will fix that right
up letting you still use turrets for
yourself and then there's repair which
lets you fix up machines like turrets or
operators and broken power generators
but even more importantly you can repair
broken recyclers and fabricators you'll
need spare parts in order to repair
something so it's also a good idea to
get dismantle which lets you break down
the spare guns you pick up into parts
finally I would recommend putting points
into toughness which increases your
overall health pool it's pretty
important in the later half when the
enemies start getting real tough you
should also put points into physicians
so you don't have to use too many med
kits
and those are the neuro mods we think
you should get no matter what play style
you are going with use the rest of your
mods on whatever cool abilities strike
your fancy let us know what mods are
your favorites I personally like turning
the dead into my own private army and
for more videos on prey and our full
review stay tuned to game spot
you
[Music]